trade wars is the flipside of sleeping
dogs sleeping dogs was all about the
story of Wei Shen and taking you on on a
ride through along that story and
finding out what was gonna happen o hn
tried wars is the other side of that
which is it's all about Hong Kong and
it's all about the criminal underworld
within Hong Kong and this is about you
creating your own game tribe boys is an
open-world action strategy game it's an
online game it's a PC title it's a game
that's gonna change and evolve over time
as people play it it's really a kind of
unique experience it's all about being a
triad gangster he was fighting his way
to the top it's about going out raiding
real rivals taking their stuff it's
about building up your empire we'd built
this whole world with a simulation of
Hong Kong and we built this great action
mechanics we've got great driving great
shooting great running great fighting
and we sort of thought can we do with
this now
this was really a chance to explore Hong
Kong and again the Triads and how that
fit together
in this game you play an enforcer
running a gang in the Hong Kong triads
and you build up your gang and your turf
and you build basically a criminal
empire about ownership it's about I get
to go into this place deal with
something up and own a piece of it build
it up protect it go and raid other
peoples turf take things from them so
you get to immerse yourself into that
Hong Kong gangster world your turf is
interesting because it's really an
extension of the player's personality
the types of rackets that you choose to
run whether you choose to focus on
counterfeiting Goods and counterfeiting
currency smuggling things it'll change
the way that you approach your game day
to day it's an open world game in those
kinds of games you don't actually see
this level of combat you can do whatever
you want to do in order to defeat those
eyes this game doesn't tell a linear
story where every players can have the
same experience
when you play this you have a different
experience from everyone else who plays
it to get to the top in triad wars you
got to be strong and you got to be smart
that means you got to go out you got to
raid real people you have to make smart
decisions to get the most out of that so
that you can rise to the top
then tried where's the community is
everything in some ways tried Wars is
even a response to things that people
have been telling us they want we want
you to help us make this game we want to
know what you want to see what do you
love what do you hate to heart a lot
care I mean as a team this is something
that's really close to close to all of
us you know we're kind of pouring our
hearts into these games and now to be
able to have the conversation they which
community and and build it into
something that we both want that's
pretty exciting
this thing's a living breathing thing
and this thing is just gonna keep
evolving and you know I'm excited to
figure out what it's gonna be in two
years it could be a completely different
game and that's we're really exciting
it's not an uneven playing field it's a
game where anyone can have fun and be
competitive when we set out to build
trade wars we set out to build a fine
game and that's really all that matters
Hong Kong is a city that you just can't
help but fall in love with the grit the
the unique character we feel like
there's a lot of room to give you new
experiences to push players in new ways
we all love games we've talked about
games we play games so for us it's a
lifestyle look I love this trade wars is
a pure sandbox where you get to choose
what to do it's going to be really
interesting to see how players choose to
use those features how to use those
tools and the types of experiences are
going to come out of that we're really
excited to be given the chance to
actually produce more in that world push
the boundaries of it to give you new
experiences and new characters really
deliver something fresh and new set in
that world I think is an amazing
opportunity you pull like two things
about Sleeping Dogs they really love the
cop aspect or they really love the crime
aspect so we made this one for the
criminals